[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy estamos
con el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france 24 doctor buen día gracias por
estar con nosotros nuevamente colombia
atraviesa por un momento crítico en la
pandemia con una tercera oleada que está
generando más de 16.000 casos diarios y
un récord de muertes que se acercan a
las 500 por día a qué se debe esta nueva
ola doctor
tenemos unos determinantes sociales raúl
y también el periodo de break en semana
santa
motivo la las aglomeraciones familiares
las reuniones familiares la movilidad
social y la idea las playas y esto ha
llevado a que haya mayor interacción
social probablemente con la circulación
de variantes que están en la región se
ha incrementado los pasos y
definitivamente nuestro sistema de salud
es frágil y se puede llenar muy
fácilmente entonces estamos ante una
situación compleja donde son los
determinantes sociales las
comportamiento viral los determinantes
virales y nuestro sistema de salud lo
que estamos padeciendo y como tercera
ola ahora doctor como lo están viviendo
ustedes el personal médico en la clínica
marly en bogotá donde usted dirige la
respuesta al coach 19
es un ejemplo de lo que está pasando en
todas las clínicas y hospitales del país
donde el personal de salud sigue
decidido trabajando sin descanso pero es
nítidamente agobiado y desgastado por la
gran cantidad de pacientes que están
llegando y la limitación de los recursos
y el espacio físico tenemos muy pocas
unidades de contención y cada vez más
limitado las fuentes de oxígeno de alto
flujo los medicamentos la sedación es
decir que estamos trabajando fuerte y
decididamente pero siempre con esa
inminencia de que podemos colapsar por
eso hay que mantener la disciplina
social los equipos de salud seguimos muy
sólidos seguimos al frente pero
obviamente estamos agobiados agotados y
esperamos que esto disminuya en un par
de semanas claro que sí doctor terrible
la situación me imagino y le pregunto si
hay diferencias en los pacientes que
están recibiendo en esta oleada frente a
momentos anteriores
es una versión del 2021 329 tenemos dos
situaciones son enfermedad que afecta
más a los jóvenes es mucho más agresiva
el daño es más pulmonar cuando nos
inflamación pero por otro lado tenemos
que las personas están automedicando
consultando tardíamente a veces rechazan
los tratamientos médicos todo debido a
una mala información que tienen sobre la
prestación de la enfermedad entonces
esto hace que sea mucho más complejo de
tratar la enfermedad hoy que lo que
hemos tratado en el año anterior y
probablemente tengamos que hacer
pedagogía y esforzarnos más para poder
que las personas confíen en la medicina
en los médicos y en los hospitales
doctor entonces le pregunto a qué cree
que se dan estas falsas ideas de las
personas y qué se puede hacer para
contrarrestarlas
es necesario entender primero que la
vacunación es importante porque hay
personas que llegan al hospital es
vacuna que no sean vacunados pudieran
tener el acceso lo segundo es que si
bien el tratamiento es un tratamiento
simple que se le hace es un tratamiento
que necesitamos armonía y no hay
remedios mágicos caseros no hay
medicación que haya demostrado realmente
la eficacia para prevenir el coito y se
están demorando mucho los presentes en
ingresar a los hospitales para recibir
tratamiento adecuado de ahí a qué se
debe llamar al médico se debe asistir en
la medicina no solamente consultar al
google para poder tomar medicamentos
sino yendo a los hospitales se puede
dirigir una terapia para para la joven
es igual no y además como si fuera poco
colombia pasa por un momento de protesta
de indignación ciudadana frente al
gobierno del presidente iván duque estas
manifestaciones masivas que han tenido
lugar pueden representar un riesgo de
mayor contagio
es preocupante esos determinantes
sociales porque sin duda en las
actividades que son allá del al aire
libre como las marchas pues es poco y la
prueba de contagio sin embargo son las
reuniones que se derivan de esas
actividades sociales en donde se pierden
añadió seguridad y se hace el
acercamiento y puede incrementar los
casos realmente estos determinantes
sociales también van a causarnos un
problema no ahora sino en unas una o dos
semanas y por esos llamados a la
sensatez a las no reunión es limitar y a
mantener el distanciamiento físico no es
ser ajeno a la realidad social pero
mantener nuestra disciplina porque la
única forma que disminuyamos los casos
en un futuro próximo
doctor carlos un gusto gracias
nuevamente por estar con nosotros como
siempre a ustedes también gracias
continúan con nosotros y muy buen día
[Música]